so it's been one year since we've all
gotten this [ __ ] scared out of us so
let's just go do it again Paranormal
Activity 2 because when a movie costs
like a thousand bucks to make and it
makes over 100 million there's gonna be
a sequel
alright so it's no secret that I really
liked Paranormal Activity 1 there's some
about the simplicity of it and a small
budget that just made it seem real and
now we have a bigger budget and more
cameras good thing oh yes and no so once
again we have a demon terrorizing a
family and we go to the movie to get the
[ __ ] scared out of us because I mean
let's face it we're not at the movie
theater for the overpriced popcorn so
now we have a bunch of nanny cams in
this house covering multiple rooms
including the swimming pool where
nothing ever happens
I only [ __ ] about it because every day
it starts out and it shows the view of
the swimming pool at night and you're
expecting something to happen nothing
ever happens so please next time don't
show us the swimming pool it's like a
blonde it's just a big tease but
Paranormal Activity 2 does have more of
what you love from the first one I mean
creepy as ambient noise it has the same
sound effects even some demon hitting
the wall and freaking you out some new
effects some I like some I didn't like
like you know the scene in paranormal
activity one where she gets dragged
across the floor by her foot I mean
scary [ __ ] right also scary because she
was in her bed covered by her blanket I
mean everything knows that the blankets
like a force field against evil at night
I mean demons have no respect for the
rules now the girl and Paranormal
Activity 2 gets dragged by her foot but
she's suspended in the air which made me
think strings which makes me think it's
not real which makes me just it just
takes me out of it which pisses me off I
mean what can I say the lower budget
from the first one just kept it sincere
I mean bigger isn't always better when
it comes to paranormal things but it
does not change the fact that I did jump
in some scenes in this movie I mean some
scenes just creeped me out I mean the
ambient noise is just like the first one
it's creepy as hell and as a disclaimer
no CGI was used in the making of this
movie I don't think there are a couple
scenes that could be CGI but it's not
you know it's not like the ring and [ __ ]
you know the scene from the trailer
where the ring girl is just standing in
the doorway like there she's just
standing there and that scenes not even
in the movie so I don't know why it's in
the trailer but I was glad it wasn't in
the movie so it looks like the grudge
and [ __ ] I didn't like that so in the
end if you liked the first one you
should watch this one I mean it's more
the stuff you like from the first one
nothing will beat the first time you saw
Paranormal Activity one but this is
really solid especially for a sequel and
if you have seen the first one there are
a couple of elements in this one that
you'll appreciate a lot more I can't
tell you more than that but it's true
so Paranormal Activity 2 is scare tastic
aha if you like the first one it's a new
rating if you were one of the people who
was bitching about the first one being
boring or slow then don't watch this
movie because it's pretty much more of
the same stuff so you won't like it but
the first one does have a leg up because
it violated the bedroom and people in
their beds
against the rules but when I got home
you know dark house and whatnot I was
walking around and saw the bathroom it
was all dark and [ __ ] and it creeped me
out so I mean that's not nothing but if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more than click right here
to see more
[Music]